le lac léman en hiver un petit lac peu
profond aux limites de la ville de
québec
lala qui est en train de mourir sur tout
les plans écologique que les plantes
aquatiques qui sont encore là et arrive
peut arriver à maturité et les 7 10 mars
et même plus une scène immense et de la
boue qui sent les odeurs infectes
l'anoxie au cours des ans des plantes
aquatiques ont disparu certains poissons
peine à y survivre
et si que ses hommes étaient détruites
passerai quelques jours ça sauverait ça
c'est sûr où il survivrait pas sans
bloquerait leur exutoire la source du
problème se situe ici sur les routes qui
longent le lac léman
chaque hiver les autorités
gouvernementales et pendent des sels de
voirie les lacs d'eau douce deviennent
progressivement salins le lac léman est
un cas extrême
il est considéré toxiques mais d'autres
lacs dans la province ont des
concentrations de chlorure de sodium
nettement plus élevé que ce qu'on
devrait y retrouver
mélissa laniel a analysé loups de 300 la
khl dans la région des laurentides on a
des lacs par exemple comme le lac à la
truite
oulala carré en termes de concentration
à sodium
ça peut aller jusqu'à 50 fois par
rapport au lac naturel
partout où le chargé de sceller ces
filtres
cela crée des dommages aux plantes
aquatiques et terrestres à la
composition du sol
consciente du problème plusieurs
municipalités réduisent la quantité de
sel de déglaçage
le ministère des transports a aussi revu
ses sharks d'épandage
mais il faudra être patient avant de
voir des changements qu'on arrête d'un
médecin ça me reste dans le sol pendant
30 40 ans donc ça va prendre plusieurs
années avant que même si en coupe à la
source key qu'elle avait pas que ça
fasse sentir au niveau du plan d'eau ici
ginette marceau radio canada québec